since the Apple watch went on sale in
April the SmartWatch wars have really
heated up this is the new Moto 360 and
it's a serious contender for the best
SmartWatch out there the new 360 fixes
the two big complaints people had with
the original the excessively large size
and the lack of all-day battery life you
can still get a 46 millimeter 360 if
that size works for you otherwise you
cannot for the smaller 42 millimeter
option like I did instead of the band
feeding right into the case there are
now lugs like on a traditional watch
which makes the 360 a lot more
comfortable you can also swap out the
watch straps quickly and easily and
you're not limited to Moto's options the
entire thing is customizable through the
Moto maker website letting you pick your
size color bezel and strap not to
mention the watch face that will pop up
when you first turn it on I went for
something simple and classic but you can
go a little crazy too if that's your
thing as for battery moto quotes a full
day of mixed use and I found this to be
pretty spot-on over a week of use I
didn't bottomed out once but I did need
to pop the thing into the magnetic
charging cradle each night luckily it
doubles as a nice looking alarm clock
while juicing up just like the original
the new 360 is running Google's Android
wear software it doesn't encourage quite
as many app interactions as say Apple's
watch OS but it surfaces useful
information like weather news sports
scores and Fitness data that you can
customize through Google now all the
stuff you expect to be there works just
fine notifications come through quickly
and fitness tracking seems about as
accurate as any other and uses Moto's
mode of body app which can also feed to
Google fit for good measure speaking of
the Apple watch
now that Android wear works with iOS
slick watches like the 360 offered
diehard iPhone lovers an alternative for
their wrists there's nothing
revolutionary or paradigm changing about
the second generation Moto 360 and
that's just fine smartwatches are still
primitive devices when compared to
something like smartphones and attempted
changing the game usually result in ugly
watches with bloated software good
industrial design and low friction
experiences are what makes a SmartWatch
break for now and the Moto 360 nails
both